July 2nd 1937 7,000 miles of empty ocean
stand between Amelia Earhart and her
bold attempt to be the first to fly
around the world following the equator
she and her navigator Fred Noonan take
off from lay new guinea for Howland
Island a speck of sand in the middle of
the Pacific it was the last anyone would
see of her after a desperate search
comes up empty
the US Navy concludes Earhart ran out of
gas and ditched into the open ocean near
Howland Island her Lockheed Electra lies
thousands of feet down on the ocean
floor case closed
it is the logical conclusion but there
is no hard evidence to prove it not a
trace of wreckage was found floating
there was no mayday call there was no
distress call for 70 years investigators
have been trying to solve the Earhart
and nygma many are convinced the crash
and sank theory is wrong in the days
after Earhart's disappearance the
speculation begins reports of SOS calls
from her radio give the world hope that
she is still alive
they a night messages alternating
between hope and disappointment crackle
from the South Seas the search swings
around the area from which her last
message was received in a desperate
effort to solve the mystery of Amelia
Earhart's fate we have found things on
the island that we can't explain unless
they came from Earhart share some
believed Earhart and Noonan landed 300
miles off target on a deserted Atoll and
died as castaways
many are convinced by eyewitness
accounts that they strayed to Japanese
occupied territory and were captured and
held as spies others go even further
believing Earhart had an ulterior
mission to gather intelligence on
Japanese military expansion in the
Pacific using forensic photographic
analysis they are out to prove Earhart
returned to the United States under
cover of a secret identity all the
competing theories are plausible but
which holds up under a critical eye
there is no evidence that she crashed at
sea it was just an aircraft accident she
returned as somebody else
Earhart survived there's no question
about it